do you know what this kid looks like
let's get his backpack too
[Music]
you know what i want to talk to you
about
you don't know
all right do me a favor keep your hands
out of your pockets for me
okay take your backpack off well
all right so
somebody reported that they have a photo
of you
and in the photo it looks like there's
some sort of a weapon sticking out of a
pocket or
take your hands out of your pocket
okay do me a favor just lift your
sweatshirt up
turn around for me
turn around again lift your sweatshirt
up again
what is that
relax
okay
anything else i need to be concerned
about
um
[Music]
all right don't move
this back door i'm not going to parade
you through the gym but we're going to
go to my office and we're going to do
the investigation
grab this bag for me
are you